herzlich willkommen liebe hörerinnen und
hörer zum einspruch podcast heute folge
185 wir freuen uns sehr dass sie wieder
dabei sind mein name ist helene
bobrowski ich moderiere den podcast
einmal im monat und bin politik
korrespondentin im berliner büro der faz
und bei mir ist heute wieder
lorenz ich bin juristin und freie
journalistin in köln 9
wir haben heute einiges vor einer die
papiere zunächst einmal müssen wir uns
noch mal mit dem thema corona
beschäftigen das beschäftigt ja
mittlerweile wieder ganz deutschland und
natürlich auch die politik insbesondere
die neue koalition bzw die drei parteien
die gerade dabei sind eine koalition zu
bilden und heute abend übrigens
ihre die ergebnisse der arbeitsgruppen
geben wollen also es geht es ans
eingemachte
genau es geht dann in die haupt
verhandlungsgruppen es geht einen
schritt voran wir sind gespannt da
können wir vielleicht nächste woche mehr
erzählen jetzt geht es aber erstmal
darum dass die drei parteien sich
gedanken gemacht haben was man denn tun
kann und muss um die ja sich wieder
aufbäumende nächste corona welle die
sogenannte vierte welle in den griff zu
bekommen und dabei wollen sie ja und das
ist ein bisschen erstaunlich die notlage
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite
auslaufen lassen was ich da dessen
vorhaben werden wir hier besprechen ihr
habt das letzte woche schon besprochen
jetzt weiß man aber etwas mehr glamour
mittlerweile gesetzentwurf vor der
immerhin irgendwie über 60 seiten lang
ist und nach vorlage des gesetzentwurfs
am montag kam dann am dienstag schon
noch neue updates dazu das schauen wir
uns kurz an damit jeder einigermaßen up
to date und gucken noch mal wie sinnvoll
das eigentlich alles so ist ob das im
moment ein guter moment dafür ist und du
helene hast auch noch andere schöne
änderungen für uns dabei nämlich es gibt
noch änderungen für die jura nerds in
den 277 bis 279 stgb die schauen wir uns
detailliert an und du hast mit dem
kollegen gesprochen über die politischen
implikationen
all diese lustigen neuen pläne für den
corona winter in deutschland
genau und dann haben wir noch was aus
dem bereich der strafjustiz
genau der bundesgerichtshof hat die
anhörungsrüge von beate treppe abgelehnt
die hat aber derweil auch schon
verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt worum es
da geht und warum die verteidiger von
beate treppe glauben sie könnten
vielleicht doch noch mal eine
verhandlung vor dem bundesgerichtshof
erreichen erzählen wir euch ebenfalls
genauso habe ich noch dabei für euch den
generalanwalt in der rubrik was kommt
der schaut sich nämlich die
anwaltskosten für filesharing und co in
deutschland mal an und soll seiner
ansicht dazu vorlegen ob die deutsche
streitwert deckelung auf 1000 euro mit
eu recht vereinbar ist und wir haben
natürlich wie immer unsere lieblings
kategorie das gerechte urteil genau da
geht es heute um das waffenrecht und die
rechtsextreme partei dritter weg
[Musik]
ja aber wie angekündigt legen wir los
mit dem thema corona können auch und dem
der nicht mehr verlängerung dem
auslaufen der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite die ampelkoalition
hat eben wie angekündigt vorhin am
montag ein erster gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt der vorsieht dass es jetzt
konkrete massnahmen geben soll die
wesentlich also ein konkreter und
abschließender katalog der schon
einigermaßen eingeschränkt sein soll
gegenüber dem was bisher möglich war was
eben aufgrund der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite möglich war lena
hat schon gesagt wir haben das letzte
woche schon relativ ausführlich
diskutiert daher jetzt mal so ein
bisschen die kurzfassung es kommt einem
wahrscheinlich in dieser woche noch
merkwürdiger vor als in der vergangenen
woche dass die epidemische lage jetzt
auslaufen soll wo die zahlen hat jetzt
höher liegen als je zuvor also wir sind
jetzt heute wir zeichnen auf am mittwoch
bei einer inzidenz von 232,1 und die
zahlen steigen weiter es gibt schon
mehrere hundert intensivstationen in
deutschland die den betrieb einschränken
müssen natürlich ist das regional
weiterhin total unterschiedlich also
bayern sachsen und thüringen liegen in
den instanzen über 400 in bremen und
schleswig holstein gegen die die grenzen
unter 100 deswegen ist es natürlich
nicht völlig fernliegend zu sagen wir
möchten den ländern jetzt die
instrumente an die hand geben um das
irgendwie weiterhin rechtlich sicher
aufzustellen ob man jetzt dieses signal
senden sollte dass die epidemische lager
ausläuft kann man mal dahingestellt
lassen das ist natürlich auch in weiten
teilen auf die fdp zurückzuführen die
der relativ großen druck markt um sich
da wie gern und stets als besonders
freiheitliche partei zu präsentieren
wobei ich noch mal nachgeschaut habe und
tatsächlich im august bei der letzten
verlängerung hatten auch die grünen
gegen eine abermalige verlängerung
gestimmt das fand ich ganz interessant
die sich ja sonst immer als team
vorsicht präsentiert hatten man kann ja
auch wirklich darüber diskutieren ob
jetzt am ende das so viel ändert an dem
was wirklich verhängt werden kann also
es ist ja tatsächlich eher so ein
bisschen ein rechtliches argument dass
man sagt naja eigentlich wollen wir
nicht hier überschießend dinge möglich
machen die einfach angesichts einer
impfquote von immerhin ja doch fast 70
prozent zumindest in der fläche und
bundesweit mit sicherheit nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig werden also eben lockt
downs ausgangssperren und so weiter lok
downs und ausgangssperren übrigens
anderer ansicht tun jetzt wieder
christian drosten und offensichtlich
auch karl lauterbach aber in dem papier
das jetzt vorgelegt wurde in dem
gesetzentwurf von den ampel parteien
steht dass nicht mehr drin also
ausdrücklich sollen nicht mehr möglich
sein logins ausgangssperren
branchenspezifische betriebsschließungen
es gibt auch kein wort zu irgendwelchen
im pflichten auch nicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen was ja doch relativ
ernsthaft an diskutiert worden war vor
allem für pflegende oder allgemeinen
mitarbeitenden in pflege und
medizinischen einrichtungen
das ist allerdings auf länder ebene
schon längst möglich sagen da die ampel
parteien vor allem deswegen hätten sie
es nicht so richtig mit aufgenommen was
bleibt ist die massen pflegt also es
bleibt abstand halten es kann weiterhin
der zugang zur gastronomie und keiner
auch fitnessstudios kann abhängig
gemacht werden von 3g oder auch zweig
meinetwegen auch zweig plus das bleibt
alles möglich es bleibt darauf legt das
papier großen wert bei allen hygiene
konzept anforderungen und arbeitsschutz
vorgaben in den betrieben da gibt es
sogar jetzt noch updates und es bleibt
auch bei auflagen damit schulen und
kitas offen bleiben können und bei
alledem bleibt das wirklich quarantäne
anordnungen zu verhängen also wenn
jemand tatsächlich irgendwie kontakt
hatte zu einem infizierten man kann in
solchen fällen wenn es weiterhin große
ausbrüche gibt auch weiterhin schulen
schließen und so weiter das alles bleibt
möglich das ganze spannend heute soll am
30 märz 2022 auslaufen ich glaube auch
das kann man jetzt einfach mal
unkommentiert erst mal stehen lassen wie
gesagt das ist der stand heute
sagen noch mal kurz schulschließungen
das interessiert ja alle eltern
insbesondere und kita schließungen soll
sollen auch bundesweit nicht mehr
pauschal jedenfalls möglich sein sondern
nur im fall eines ausbruchs ich war
genau genau also so verstehe ich das
papier relativ deutlich ist dass es
formuliert sozusagen die möglichkeit von
auflagen und zwar genauso damit schulen
und kitas offen bleiben können also das
schließt für mich erst mal eine
pauschale schließung aus aber wenn eben
es ausbrüche gibt oder so dann soll es
natürlich weiterhin möglich bleiben auf
dich zu machen was man natürlich nicht
vergessen darf ist das ist jederzeit
möglich wäre dass der bundestag wieder
beschließt das ist eine epidemische
notlage von oder eine chemische lage von
nationaler tragweite gibt und dann wäre
eben um jetzt mal im paragrafen zu
nennen wieder der 28 absatz 1
infektionsschutzgesetz käme zur
anwendung und dann wäre der ganze
katalog der einschränkung die auch
weiter gehen also zum beispiel ein lock
down und schließung auch pauschale
schließung wäre dann wieder möglich das
heißt die rhetorik dieser ampel parteien
ist schon interessant die sich
hinstellen und sagen es wird mit uns
kein lockdown geben da haben sie sich
vielleicht auch ein bisschen verhoben
das ist ja nun auch schon zwei wochen
her diese ankündigung ich weiß nicht ob
sie das heute so wiederholen würden weil
man doch man erinnert sich an den
november vor einem jahr den lockdown
leid auch damals hieß es es wird kein
lockdown geben keine echten keine
schulschließung
und vier wochen später war es soweit
wie gesagt es ist es ist möglich ist es
nur jetzt nicht möglich weil die
voraussetzungen nicht mehr gegeben sind
namentlich die epidemische lage genau
und es gebe auch noch die möglichkeit
dass eben nicht nur bundesweit auch
relativ unproblematisch genau wie du
sagst wenn er komplett wieder
einzuführen sondern im moment haben ja
auch die länder die möglichkeit die
konkrete gefahr der epidemischen
ausbreitung in einem bundesland
festzustellen das heißt irgendwie selbst
zu machen diese möglichkeit soll jetzt
auslaufen also das soll auch aus dem 28
raus fliegen aber man könnte sich
natürlich überlegen gerade angesichts
der jetzt wieder massiv steigenden
instanzen ob man das auch einfach drin
lässt damit würde man den ländern die ja
jetzt schon meckern und sagen ihr nehmt
uns echt einige instrumente weg
natürlich auch sozusagen alle freiheiten
wiedergeben und sagen ihr könnt das
eigentlich selber feststellen dann
wiederum nicht nur das was wir jetzt in
der abschließenden liste drin haben im
gesetzentwurf im moment ist das aber
nicht vorgesehen also jetzt hier will
ich hier keine verwirrung stiften ist
ging aber auch so und dann wurde nach
der nach dem bekanntwerden des
gesetzentwurfs am montag kam am dienstag
schon das erste update also ich glaube
wir können uns darauf einstellen dass
wir da irgendwie für die nächsten ein
zwei wochen noch eine menge updates
hinterher schieben müssen zum ersten mal
wird das im bundestag besprochen am
donnerstag jetzt wurde wie gesagt am
dienstag schon nachgeschoben dass die
ampel koalitionäre sich auch darauf
geeinigt haben dass die kostenlosen
schnelltests für bürger wieder
eingeführt werden wir erinnern uns bis
zum 11 oktober waren die kostenlos das
sollte dann wurde gekippt um den druck
auf ungeimpfte zu erhöhen das hat ganz
offensichtlich nicht funktioniert wird
jetzt als fehlentscheidung eingeschätzt
und soll wieder rückgängig gemacht
werden und ziemlich wichtig am
arbeitsplatz soll künftig generell 3g
gelten also das dürfte dann nur noch
arbeiten gehen wer geimpft oder genesen
ist oder einen aktuellen negativen test
vorlegen kann mitarbeitende in der
pflege sollen auf jeden fall täglich
getestet werden bei allen anderen ist
das noch relativ unklar also es ist noch
unklar wie häufig müssen ungeimpfte
vielleicht auch alle weiß man ja nicht
auch das ist im gespräch sich dann
künftig testen lassen im moment ist es
ja so dass zweimal in der woche die
arbeitgebenden kostenlosen test zur
verfügung stellen müssen mindestens das
volvo so bleiben es ist auch eine
tägliche test licht im gespräch unklar
ist auch noch was ist wenn man es nicht
macht verliert man dann seinen anspruch
auf lohnzahlung was also wenn man sich
weigert unklar sind auch noch die frage
und auskunftsrechte des arbeitgebers die
ihr mittlerweile also die ja bisher noch
nicht so richtig angefasst wurden und
das ganze soll jetzt das
bundesarbeitsministerium binnen einer
woche aus arbeiten auch dieser
gesetzentwurf soll der nächste woche vom
bundestag beschloss
und dann haben wir noch eine sehr
hübsche geplante gesetzesänderung dabei
die auch überhaupt nicht befristet ist
und kein verfallsdatum hat und das ist
was da muss man sagen da lacht das herz
der yuan absolut man fühlt sich wieder
zurückversetzt in die zeiten von
strafrecht besonderer teil im studium
weil all diese schönen dinge wie
schriftliche lüge bei der
urkundenfälschung und wenn der
aussteller und der
in der sichtbaren der tatsächlich und
der erkennbare ausstellung auseinander
fallen und als solche dinge haben mich
jetzt wieder beschäftigt hat sich mir
diese änderungen des geplanten
änderungen des strafgesetzbuches
angeschaut habe da geht es um die
paragraphen
277 folgenden eigentlich ein bereich der
im studium keine besondere relevanz hat
nämlich die fälschung von
gesundheitszeugnisse warum ist denn das
jetzt relevant vielleicht gibt es uns
erst mal kurz den sachverhalt das ganze
hat zu tun mit einer entscheidung des
landgerichts osnabrück von in oktober
ein fall einer von sehr sehr vielen also
geht es von tausenden
ermittlungsverfahren wo es ähnlich
gelaufen ist jemand hat sich einen
gefälschten impfpass beschafft die im
internet ungefähr 450 euro zu haben sind
also so einen gefälschten papieren
gefälschten papier impfpass mit zwei
kurven impfungen drin also aufkleber
stempel und so weiter und es damit in
die apotheke gegangen und hat sich ein
digitales zertifikat geholt das
dramatische an der sache ist dass in dem
moment in dem man ein digitales
zertifikat hat die fälschung nicht mehr
nachweisbar ist dann wie wir das ja alle
tun zeigen wir nur noch die die app auf
unserem handy und es ist überhaupt nicht
mehr nachzuvollziehen dass man
ursprünglich eben nicht geimpft ist
jetzt würde man doch aber eigentlich als
normaler mensch denken das muss doch
irgendwie strafbar sein wenn ich damit
nicht irgendwie ein gesundheitszeugnis
falsche oder so genau es gibt auch
tatsächlich gerichte die das m für
strafbar befunden haben das landgericht
osnabrück kommt aber zu einem anderen
ergebnis die wände neben die eben schon
zitiert enorm des
277 an die fälschung von gesundheits
zeugnissen und sagen zwei jahre es ist
dieser impfpass ist natürlich ein
gesundheitszeugnis aber eine weitere
tatbestandsvoraussetzungen dieser norm
ist dass das zeugnis bei behörden oder
versicherungsgesellschaften vorgelegt
wird und zu ihrer täuschung dient dann
und dann ab so hier gilt wer das schnell
noch eine versicherungsgesellschaft
naja die apotheke ist keine
versicherungsgesellschaft und auch keine
behörde sondern schlichtweg ein privates
unternehmen also schnell unter diese
norm subsumiert kommt man so ein
ergebnis der 277 ist ganz offensichtlich
hier nicht einschlägig jetzt stellt sich
die schwierige juristische frage kann
man denn auf das allgemeine recht der
urkundenfälschung also
267 zurückgreifen was übrigens höher
bestraft ist also ein strafraum bis zu
fünf jahren während der 277 nur zwei bis
zu zwei jahre vorsieht und jetzt ist es
tatsächlich eine rechts dogmatische
frage die unterschiedlich beurteilt wird
er hat diese
mildere normen des 277 entfaltet das
eine sperrwirkung aufgrund der
privilegierung so dass der rückgriff auf
die allgemeine urkundenfälschung
versperrt ist ja oder nein und das
landgericht osnabrück hat sehr klar
gesagt ja es gibt eine solche
sperrwirkung deswegen ist der rückgriff
nicht möglich wenn es eben kalt wenn die
fälschung von
gesundheitszeugnisse nicht nach 277
strafbar ist dann ist sie hat insgesamt
nicht strafbar also das heißt das
argument ist irgendwie der die norm bis
277 ist spezieller und wenn die nicht
greift kann ich nicht auf den allgemein
hab ich endlich abschließen was die
gesundheitszeugnisse angehen ich finde
das ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich
einleuchtend weil die
tatbestandsvoraussetzungen so eng sind
dass man sich schwerlich vorstellen kann
dass jegliches andere schindluder um es
mal so zu sagen dass man mit gesundheits
zeugnissen sonst noch treiben kann
straffrei ist
man muss natürlich berücksichtigen dass
diese norm aus einer zeit stammt in der
so etwas wie digitalisierung von in
pässen oder digitale zertifikate denkens
gebert daran natürlich schlicht nicht
gedacht hat andere gerichte kommen zu
anderen
ergebnissen zum beispiel das
amtsgericht wolfsburg hat gesagt dass es
kleine urkundenfälschung warum soll so
eine sperrwirkung geben jetzt hat das
bundesjustizministerium dass ich schon
seit zwei wochen mit der frage
konfrontiert sieht haben wir deine
strafbarkeitslücken was übrigens das
landgericht osnabrück exakt so
bezeichnet hat als strafbarkeitslücken
und das bundesjustizministerium hat
gesagt wir prüfen weil so ein bisschen
oder auch meinetwegen sehr engagiert
aber hat erkennen lassen da soll erst
mal nichts großes passieren sondern
irgendwann müsste man sicherlich die
singenden diesen ganzen bereich mal
überarbeiten aber das könnte jetzt so
heute die polter nicht funktionieren so
sinngemäß war es zu hören das hilft uns
natürlich in der aktuellen krise wenig
kenner und dann kam auch direkt die
union in ihrer neuen rolle als
opposition und hat einen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt in dem diese strafbarkeit
lücke geschlossen wird und die ampel
parteien wollten sich dann aber von der
cdu csu nicht so vor sich hertreiben
lassen und haben dann gesagt na gut dann
arbeiten wir halt diesen gesetzentwurf
zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes noch mal nach
und nehmen eben eine änderung auch des
rechtes der fälschung der
gesundheitszeugnisse dazu und ehrlich
gesagt die interessant ist der
interessanteste aspekt findet sich in
der gesetzesbegründung denn dort ist
klipp und klar
festgeschrieben dass die 277 keine
sperrwirkung entfalten gegenüber der eu
konkrete und die diese gesetzes
begründungen sind natürlich durchaus
relevant für die auslegung der normen
das heißt das ist mal der erste punkt
der klargestellt es anders als das
landgericht osnabrück argumentiert hat
ist es eben so dass wenn die 277 nicht
einschlägig ist dann wird eben das kommt
eher 267 also der normale die normale
urkundenfälschung zum tragen und so eine
sperrwirkung gibt es nicht denn so heißt
es da ein impfpass ein
gesundheitszeugnis ist ganz klar eine
urkunde dann ist aber das ist ganz
interessant eigentlich diese dieses
etwas verworrene
rechtsgebiet oder diese dieser und
dieses unklare verhältnis der
urkundenfälschung zum tatbestand der
fälschung von gesundheitszeugnisse
tatsächlich jetzt nach dem vorschlag der
ampel parteien etwas geordnet worden und
zwar haben sie gesagt eigentlich macht
es überhaupt keinen sinn dass im 277
auch noch die varianten fälschung von
ihm fälschung von gesundheits zeugnissen
und gebrauch von gesundheits zeugnissen
geregelt sind denn dabei handelt es sich
eigentlich nur sonderformen der
urkundenfälschung und die sollen unter
den normalen tatbestand fallen und dann
haben sie gesagt ist bleibt ein ganz
kleiner anwendungsbereich nur für den
277 übrig und jetzt kommen wir zum
begriff der schriftlichen lüge wenn sich
die jura studenten erinnern oder
vielleicht auch gerade dabei sind das
recht der urkundenfälschung
durchzunehmen werden sie alle wissen
dass die normale schriftliche lüge keine
urkundenfälschung darstellt so weil
nämlich schriftliche lügen bedeutet zum
beispiel dass in meinem fall ich lehne
bobrowski
erkläre irgendetwas nicht stimmt aber
unter meinem namen so das ist etwas das
nicht das zwar nicht stimmt aber da ist
er der aussteller also der der als
aussteller aus der urkunde hervor geht
nämlich und der tatsächliche aussteller
fallen nicht auseinander und der fall
der jetzt unter den 277 erfasst wird
wäre ich helene bobrowski bin ernst denn
und erkläre als ärztin dass ich eine
impfung vorgenommen habe oder dass ich
einen dass ich ein impfpass ausstellen
kann oder ähnliches da täusche ich nicht
über meine identität ist also keine
identität täuschung die eine
urkundenfälschung wäre sondern es ist
eine täuschung über eine qualifikation
als ärzten ich bin ja keine ärztin und
insofern ist dieser bereich eben oder
dieser fall wäre keine urkundenfälschung
und dieser das ist ehrlich gesagt ein
ganz kleiner bereich aber dennoch einer
der nicht erfasst
wäre ansonsten nur der ist jetzt über
den 277 geregelt ansonsten ist diese
norm entschlackt also die fälschung und
der gebrauch sind daraus gestrichen in
der neuen fassung sei die jetzt unter
267 die normale urkundenfälschung fallen
genannt das soll jetzt alles über die
normale urkundenfälschung aufgefangen
werden also diese stelle landgericht
osnabrück als man lässt das
digitalisieren oder man lässt natürlich
auch alle anderen
bereich also man lässt eine urkunde man
fällt selber eine man kauft eine
gefälschte man benutzt eine gefälschte
übrigens ist gehört zur fälschung ja
auch man hat einen echten impfpass und
lässt sich
eine kopie impfung eintragen die gar
nicht vorgenommen wurde ja das ist
natürlich auch eine fälschung waldes
nicht den tatsachen entspricht und dann
gibt es noch einen ganz kleinen aspekt
ja auch wirklich sehr speziell ist das
ist echt was für für feinschmecker
das ist der
275 da ist jetzt noch einen neuen ein
neuer absatz 1a eingefügt worden in
diese norm wo es um die sogenannten
blankett impfausweise geht
langkamp ausweise sind solche wo alles
drinsteht inklusive also die impfungen
ja die angeblich vorgenommen wurden aber
natürlich nicht vorgenommen sind aber
der name noch nicht ausgefüllt ist also
das sind die fälle von fälschern die im
großen stil
blanco impfpässe herstellen aber den
namen noch nicht eintragen und die dann
über das internet vertreiben und da also
es geht übrigens ich muss das gerade
selber google neben da draußen 2 75 stgb
sanktioniert die vorbereitung der
fälschung von amtlichen ausweisen wusste
bescheid weiterhin kennt auch vielen
dank für diesen titel
und da ist eben hat argumentieren die
ampel parteien in der gesetzesbegründung
das ist da eine gewisse
rechtsunsicherheit gibt weil man nicht
genau weiß ob so ein blankett
impfausweis eigentlich schon eine
urkunde ist ja beim eben diese
personenbezogenen daten also der name
die adresse und all das was noch im kopf
drin steht noch fehlen und weil man
nicht ist nicht darauf ankommen lassen
will und sagen wir also jemand stellt
diese blankett aus weil sie hier klebt
da diese kleinen aufkleber rein und es
am ende straffreiheit man jetzt eben
diese in indien 275 diesen neuen absatz
eingefügt wo eben auch die herstellung
von lang im voraus weisen unter strafe
gestellt und weil man sagt diese
gefahren geneigt haid so der ausdruck
ist schon so hoch
dass
man mir danach nur noch den namen
eintragen muss dass es so ein minimaler
aufwand das ist das jetzt nicht sein
kann dass man nicht an schon ideen und
und das auch dann schlicht nicht mehr zu
kontrollieren ja so dass man sagt also
dieses ursprüngliche teilweise
gewerbliche herstellung von blankett
impfausweise ist jetzt auch strafbar
oder bzw soll jetzt auch strafbar sein
wir reden ja vom gesetzentwurf der am
donnerstag in erster lesung
in den bundestag geht klingt aber extrem
sinnvoll wenn ich mal kurz in diese norm
rein gucke ich bin ja ganz entzückt wie
ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo aus 1800
oder so also es geht um plattformen
druck setzte druckstöcke negative und
matrizen und um die herstellung von
papier und so weiter ich glaube es
klingt so als ob diese norm ein kleines
update gebrauchen könnte was glaube ich
auch angesichts dieses jahr wirklich
florierenden business der der fälschung
von ausweisen durchaus eine sinnvolle
änderung sein könnte genau hier also und
deswegen lag das bmj frauen natürlich
mit der einschätzung eigentlich müsste
man bei diesen ganzen bereich erneuern
und nicht immer nur ein bisschen dran
rum fricke das ist jetzt für puristen
auch sicherlich aus dieser sicht richtig
schöne gesetze machen aber gerade in
einer lage in der wir jetzt in können
wir glaube ich nicht darauf warten
ja liebe hörerinnen und hörer sie haben
gesehen ist ist tatsächlich kompliziert
die ampel macht schon gesetze obwohl die
alte bundesregierung ja noch im amt ist
namentlich der bundesgesundheitsminister
es ist also ein ziemliches kuddelmuddel
wie wir hier in berlin sagen und jetzt
haben wir einen gast bei uns der uns
hilft das ein bisschen zu entwirren sehr
schön eckart lohse ist bei mir
redaktionsleiter in berlin büroleiter
der berliner politik redaktion und vater
eines sohnes in der juristenausbildung
insofern wird er wie er sagte regelmäßig
beim abendessen mit juristischen fragen
gegrillt und da wollen wir doch direkt
mal ansetzen enovia bei uns hier genannt
wird das ist ein kürzel was sind denn
die mod merkmale
ist tatsächlich eines der prüfungsthemen
die am abendbrottisch gerne vorkommt
also ich im kommen dann nie auf alle
neuen die mir beigebracht wurden aber
ich versuche immer besondere grausamkeit
heimtücke befriedigung des
geschlechtstriebs naja also
soviel aufzuzählen wie es gerade geht
aber ich arbeite noch daran bis ich sie
dann wirklich alle neuen kann also das
jurastudium quasi privat durchgeführt im
eigenen esszimmer es ist nie zu spät
und jetzt wollen wir mal einsteigen das
politische geschäft also wird brechen
jetzt über die frage eckert wer hier
eigentlich was macht bei der korona
gesetzgebung und meine allererste frage
ist ziemlich einfach wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass die ampel die ja so
tut als sei sie schon die neue regierung
das aber natürlich noch nicht ist die
kanzler weise irgendwann anfang dezember
stattfinden warum kann die eigentlich
schon gesetze machen gesetze macht der
bundestag also macht natürlich nicht
allein aber beschließt der bundestag
kann sie auch alleine machen
insofern kennen immer in deutschland
gesetze gemacht werden denn nach einer
bundestagswahl sind maximal 30 tage zeit
bis sich der neu gewählte bundestag
konstituieren muss in diesen 30 tagen
wenn sie ausgeschöpft werden kann der
bestehende bundestag gesetze machen und
danach dann mit dem tag der
konstituierung der neue bundestag
gesetze machen das entspricht dann nur
meistens noch nicht in den mehrheiten
den nächsten regierungen außer das sind
die gleichen mehrheiten die eine
koalition bilden wie in der regierung
zuvor aber das ist hier nicht der fall
man hat aber das gefühl dass die alte
bundesregierung bei diesem gesetz über
das wir vorhin gesprochen haben doch
noch mitzuwirken hat und das mache ich
nicht zuletzt fest an dem begriff der
formulierungshilfe denn dieser
gesetzentwurf der jetzt vorliegt der hat
den titel dem merkwürdigen titel würde
ich sagen entwurf einer
formulierungshilfe für die
bundestagsfraktionen von spd bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp für ein aus der
mitte des deutschen bundestages
einzubringen das gesetz zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und so weiter
was heißt dieses wort formulierungshilfe
und vielleicht sagst du uns mal wer hat
denn jetzt dieses gesetz gemacht die
neue ampel die alte bundesregierung das
bundesgesundheitsministerium oder wer
also die der begriff formulierungshilfe
ist ja festgelegt dass sind aus der
regierung kommen ich habe mir vorschläge
meistens für änderungen an gesetzen in
diesem fall geht es um eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
und das kann auch sagen das ist eine
hilfe der exekutive die ja große
apparate hat also der noch im amt
befindlichen geschäftsführenden
regierung in diesem falle das passiert
aber auch sonst mitten in der
legislaturperiode häufig solche
formulierungshilfen erbracht werden und
in diesem falle hat es doch den eindruck
dass die initiative zwar aus den drei
fraktionen der
ampel die entstehen soll kommt das aber
die vorhandene regierung
denn die formulierung geleistet hat das
heißt sozusagen entwurf gemacht hat
diese änderungen das ist natürlich etwas
einfacher als bei einer kompletten
ablösung einer regierung denn der
hauptteil der künftigen koalition die
spd ist ja erstens teil der jetzigen
regierung hat wichtige häuser
unter anderem finanzministerium
arbeitsministerium auch
justizministerium besetzt und wird
voraussichtlich auch tragender teil der
nächsten regierung seien insofern ist es
relativ leicht wenn die drei fraktionen
sozialdemokraten fdp und
grüne dann über die vorhandene regierung
sich solche formulierungshilfen
entwickeln lassen oder schreiben lassen
muss aber auch sagen
selbst der cdu teil selbst das
kanzleramt sagt jetzt was die neue
regierung die mutmaßliche neue regierung
braucht ein hilfe und unterstützung
leisten wir auch also man darf sich das
auch nicht ganz so kriegerisch
konfrontativ vorstellen dass die dann
sagen wir machen die bude zu und hier
kam keiner mehr rein weil die in eine
regierung bilden interessant es gibt ja
leute die sagen man kann die sozusagen
den stand der zivilisatorischen
entwicklung eines landes daran ablesen
ob die neue regierung alles rückgängig
macht was die alte regierung erarbeitet
hat ich weiß nicht ob das immer stimmt
ist es sicherlich auch eine frage von
traditionen in amerika ist es zb die
tradition zu sagen elexxion meter also
es ist auch gut dass sich alles ändert
in deutschland haben wir jetzt auch ja
gesehen einen etwas sage ich mal
softeren gut organisierten übergang noch
einmal zurück also man kann jetzt
vielleicht sagen dieses gesetz dieser
gesetzentwurf der auf dem tisch liegt
ist eine art gemeinschaftsproduktion von
alter bundesregierung und der ampel und
in der tat wenn man sich den
gesetzentwurf anschaut der ja sehr
umfassend ist dann wird man schon bei
allem respekt vor den parlamentariern
sieht man schon daran dass das
mutmaßlich nicht in den kleinen
abgeordnetenbüros mit den 23
mitarbeitern die die haben geschrieben
worden ist sondern von den großen
abteilungen der ministerien insbesondere
gesundheitsministeriums die da einfach
dieses gesetzgeberische
know how die erfahrung haben wie so
etwas funktioniert war das tatsächlich
alles andere als trivial ist kurz noch
zur formulierungshilfe ist glaube ich
hat auch die folge dass das dann
schneller geht weil eine aus der mitte
des parlaments eingebrachter
gesetzentwurf nicht vorab noch in den
bundesrat muss genauso ein kleiner trick
wenn man so will aber ganz zulässig das
verfahren genau in diesem fall hat es
aber tatsächlich natürlich andere gründe
nicht wahrscheinlich auch die
beschleunigung aber eben auch diese
besondere konstellation dass eben die
mehrheiten im parlament und die
besetzung der häuser jetzt auseinander
fallen ja dass gerade schon das
kanzleramt genannt jetzt fragt man sich
ja was angela merkel eigentlich dieser
tage in dieser frage noch zu sagen hat
sie war ja immer kann man so sagen die
chefin des teams vorsicht wir erinnern
uns alle noch mit freude an ihre schöne
wort schöpfung öffnungs diskussions
orgien vor denen sie gewarnt hatte und
jetzt hat sie hier unseren kollegen der
sonntagszeitung kürzlich im interview
gesagt sie schauen mit sorge auf die
entwicklung der hospitalisierung werte
und der todeszahlen und sagte das
bereitet ihr große sorgen und es sie
mahnte auch jetzt wieder und sagte es
macht sich schon wieder eine gewisse
leichtfertigkeit breit meinst du sie
wird in den verletzten wochen wenn die
lage sich noch weiter verschärft auch
sagen jetzt ist gebietet es mein abend
selbst als geschäftsführende
bundeskanzlerin dass ich jetzt noch mal
tätig werde
natürlich sie ist ja auch bereit noch
mal wieder einen ministerpräsidenten
konferenz abzuhalten da sind ja im
moment die sozialdemokratischen
ministerpräsidenten dagegen die unions
mps sind eher bereit das zu machen das
ist sozusagen ein eigenes kapitel warum
die da unterschiedliche meinungen sind
das hat auch machtpolitische gründe die
kann sie nicht einfach einberufen als
kanzlerin sie kann dazu einladen und
dann kommt er will und wenn dann nur die
region sam ps kommen oder andere
bekommen sie also da ist ihre macht
schon eingeschränkt zu handeln selbst
wenn sie es schafft das haben wir ja
über anderthalb jahre erlebt sie alle
zusammen zu bringen kann man einen
gemeinsamen willen formulieren
tatsächlich wird aber dann trotzdem die
umsetzung in den ländern immer gemacht
das heißt auch da ist ihre macht
beschränkt in ihre macht ist noch weiter
dadurch beschränkt dass die
parlamentarische mehrheit die sie hat
zum beispiel um einen
infektionsschutzgesetz oder eine bundes
notbremse wie wir sie hatten
durchzusetzen ist ihr auch verloren
gegangen denn der koalitionsvertrag den
sie abgeschlossen hat ihr letzter 2018
mit den anderen für vier jahre der hat
jetzt faktisch seine gültigkeit verloren
in diesem koalitionsvertrag steht drin
ist darf nicht mit wechselnden
mehrheiten abgestimmt werden bedeutet
die spd dürfte jetzt gar nicht
ausscheren aus dem bündnis mit der cdu
aber der vertrag ist quasi wenn auch
nicht rechtskräftig aber politisch
abgelaufenen also darf die spd jetzt mit
fdp und grünen stimmen im bundestag und
damit hat frau merkel im bundestag keine
politische mehrheit mehr das sind also
die drei
substanziellen
einschränkungen ihrer macht trotzdem ist
sie weiter von
dem bundespräsidenten dazu darum gebeten
worden wie das üblich ist ist sie weiter
bundeskanzlerin geschäftsführende
bundeskanzlerin kann also ganz viel
machen vertritt deutschland nach außen
hin und und kann natürlich exekutiv
weiten aber wie gesagt in der korona
frage ist ihre ist eher arm ist
sozusagen die reichweite ihres armes
deutlich verkürzen es gibt ja diese
lustige anekdote von teilnehmern der mpk
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
sagt naja man bespricht sich dann vorher
unter den spd ministerpräsidentin unions
ministerpräsidenten und alle sagen nein
wir machen das auf gar keinen fall so
wie die merkel das jetzt wieder will und
wir machen darum seinen eigenen kurs in
der frage und dann versammeln sich alle
um den tisch und die kanzlerin blickt
einmal grimmig in die runde und schon
sind alle ganz klein mit hut und machen
ist mehr oder weniger am ende sie hat
sich auch nicht immer durchgesetzt aber
dies will und in der tat jetzt
klebt ja an ihr dieses hässliche wort
der lame duck die sie sicherlich schon
aufgrund ihrer langen
regierungserfahrung und so weiter hat
und der ja auch doch insgesamt würde ich
sagen in deutschland ziemlich großen
wertschätzung aber es ist eben in
gesetzgeberischen fragen wie du ja
geschrieben hast schwieriger geworden
noch ein kurzer blick auf die länder man
hat ja den eindruck also man weiß nicht
ganz genau gibt's jetzt mpk oder nicht
wird sich jetzt zeigen aber die
wir sehen ja in die länder machen doch
sowieso was sie wollen oder brandenburg
hat nun entschieden zweig einzuführen
sachsen hat das schon getan
braucht es denn dann überhaupt diese
bundeseinheitlichen regeln oder
angesichts der sage dass wir jetzt eben
keine epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite dieser zungenbrecher und dass
wir das jetzt nicht mehr haben wie
schätze dass ein naja die länder können
vieles und haben das ja auch schon
gekonnt als man noch regelmäßig
miteinander sich im fast monats oder
manchmal auch weniger als monatsrhythmus
zusammensetzte es gibt ein paar
regelungen die bundesgesetzlich sind
natürlich bei den gesamten einen
ausreise fragen
da ist es tatsächlich dann eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung und ansonsten
diente das ja vor allen dingen dafür den
ländern eine einheitliche
rechtsgrundlage zu geben auf deren basis
sie den verordnungen erlassen konnten
zur regelung
all dieser kona
maßnahmen in ihren ländern wird sagen ja
vereinen die sozialdemokraten wir haben
diese grundlagen wir schaffen eine neue
grundlage
auch wenn die
pandemische notlage endet dann haben wir
eine neue grundlage auf der wir masken
bestimmungen oder erschließungen öffnung
usw und so weiter machen können also
rechtlich stehen wir auf festem boden
wir brauchen gar kein weiteres treffen
und das war in der vergangenheit auch
immer so muss man allerdings dazu sagen
die masse die große mehrheit der
beschlüsse die in den apps ja in langen
langen protokollen festgehalten wurden
wurde auch ziemlich einheitlich in den
ländern durchgesetzt aber wie das nun
mal so ist von den medien durchaus unter
stärkt besonders hingeguckt wurde
natürlich bei den dingen die absichten
von der linie weil man dann immer sagen
konnte so gegen den bund gegen merkel
oder für merkel aber
grundsätzlich war das schon hilfreich
dass es dieses bundeseinheitliche
vorgehen gegeben hat
weil in den meisten fällen sich doch die
länder dran gehalten haben und unter
berücksichtigung natürlich dessen was
wir jetzt sehen und damals gesehen haben
dass die pandemische lage in nicht in
allen ländern gleich ausgeprägt ist also
in schleswig holstein weil sie immer
schon japan die zahlen immer schon
niedriger als jetzt etwa in sachsen eine
letzte politische frage noch an dich
eckert jetzt sehen wir also spd fdp und
grüne präsentieren einen gemeinsamen
gesetzentwurf in corona fragen und wenn
man ein bisschen zurücktritt ist es doch
verwunderlich weil doch in der korona
politik der vergangenen anderthalb jahre
wenn man mal von der afg absieht grüne
und fdp eigentlich die beiden
entgegengesetzten polen waren als die
grünen waren abgesehen von ein paar
rechtspolitikern ganz eindeutig das team
vorsicht und die fdp hat ja schon vor
monaten die beendigung der die dänischen
lage gefordert und christian lindner hat
immer vor lok da uns in anderem gewand
und was ich von den grünen gehört habe
ist es die immer gesagt haben ja in
corona ist es mit der fdp sehr sehr
schwierig als man vom halben jahr oder
von 34 jammer über die ampel sprach und
zum sommer hin haben wir gesagt naja
ampel können wir uns schon irgendwo
vorstellen oder auch jamaika mit der fdp
weil er jetzt corona ich will nicht
sagen vorbei aber weil corinna nicht
mehr so aktuell ist und deswegen haben
wir dieses problem nicht mehr auf dem
tisch jetzt haben sie das problem auf
dem tisch ist es sogar das erste
vorhaben das sie angehen und bei den
gemeinsamen auftritten hat man das
gefühl auf einmal platz passt chor oder
wer sich gar keine platten mehr zwischen
die beiden wie viel ist davon echt wie
viel es gespielt und wer von den beiden
hat sich eigentlich mehr bewegt also
erst mal hat die situation jetzt
natürlich ganz ganz viel mit der
impfstoffentwicklung zu tun also man
stelle sich vor im spätsommer frühherbst
vorigen jahres als wir bestenfalls
hoffnung auf dem stoff hatten hätte dass
diese regierungsbildung unter diese
koalitionsbildung stattgefunden wäre der
graben glaube ich so nicht zu
überbrücken gewesen weil die grünen da
natürlich wie du gesagt hast helene im
team vorsicht waren und die fdp schon
seit monaten gesagt hat jetzt aber mal
halblang und so weiter und so weiter
immer auf die freiheit und
die rechte des einzelnen gepocht haben
jetzt ist die lage anders weshalb ja im
übrigen auch ersparen klar auf cdu
klammer zu schon vor der ampel gesagt
hat man könnte die rechtsgrundlage
epidemische notlage aufheben das geht
nur weil so viele menschen geimpft sind
auch da wir gucken natürlich mal auf die
nicht geimpften aber es ist ein großer
teil schimpft man kann also mehr
freiheiten zu lassen zweitens dieser
gesetzentwurf sieht ja auch weitere
beschränkungen vor man wollte ganz
offensichtlich zeigen dass man gut
zusammenarbeitet das sollte nicht
irgendwie wenn der kleingarten
verordnung irgendwie vom münsterland
west gezeigt werden sondern man wollte
ist einem großen thema das große thema
im moment ist innenpolitisch oder auch
international natürlich die pandemie
gibt es ja auch handlungsbedarf diese
notlage läuft aus da musste also
entweder verlängerung kommen oder eine
neue grundlage und ich glaube das ganze
ist geschuldet dem willen der drei
parteien an einem großen für alle
menschen wichtigen beispiel zu sagen
selbst in einem schwierigen fall
den wir mal anderer meinung waren
kriegen wir so was miteinander hin dass
steckt politisch interessant dazu kommt
natürlich dass in der opposition immer
klappern zum geschäft gehört und jeder
klapperte da ein bisschen in die andere
richtung und jetzt in der regierung ist
die lage eine neue da gibt es schon
aufmerksamkeit wenn man einfach nur
entscheidungen trifft die man ja nach
position nicht treffen kann eckert
vielen dank dass du da was beim
einspruch podcast sehr schön kommen
hoffentlich bald mal wieder denn für uns
juristen sage ich mal es ist auch immer
sehr lehrreich jemanden zu haben der
etwas über den tellerrand hinausblicken
sich trotzdem natürlich jedenfalls am
abendbrottisch für unsere themen
begeistert hinter eckert sehr gerne
gerne wieder
so nach diesem munteren gespräch hier
sind wir zurück und sprechen jetzt über
beate treppe die uns ja wirklich schon
ich habe gerade die dem bericht
beschrieben über zehn jahre auflegen nsu
also uns wirklich zehn jahre schon
beschäftigt und der prozess begann im
mai
2013 also alleine die juristische
aufarbeitung dauert nun schon hast acht
oder mehr als acht jahre an ja der bgh
damit relativ gutem timing in der
vergangenen woche eine entscheidung
vorgelegt quasi relativ pünktlich zum
zehnten jahrestag der aufdeckung des nsu
also am 14 11 2010 haben sich
uwe bernhardt und uwe mundlos das leben
genommen planmäßig nach dem sie
praktisch aufgeflogen waren bei einem
banküberfall nach ihrer fast ja ich
glaube zehn jahre andauernden mord serie
und danach hat dann beate treppe wie das
ebenfalls geplant war öffentlich gemacht
dass diese gesamte mord serie auf dieses
trio zurückzuführen war und zehn jahre
später hat beate treppe die
bgh-entscheidung nicht akzeptiert die
wir euch relativ ausführlich vorgestellt
haben in den folgen
173 und 174 also das war alles im august
das sogenannte nsu urteil des
bundesgerichtshofs in der schon in der
vorletzten woche haben allerdings drei
ihrer verteidiger nämlich matthias
grasel das war der später dazu gekommene
verteidiger wolfgang heer das war einer
ihrer ursprungs verteidiger ihr erinnert
euch daran das war ja alles ein alptraum
mit der verteidigung in diesem verfahren
und noch der revision sun wald andreas
lickleder auch verfassungsbeschwerde
gegen das urteil eingelegt nachdem jetzt
der bgh die anhörungsrüge zurückgewiesen
hat wird jetzt also wenn es gut läuft
für beate table sag ich mal das
bundesverfassungsgericht noch über eine
verfassungsbeschwerde
entscheiden noch mal ganz kurz zurück
der bgh hatte die chip revision komplett
verworfen und das urteil des
oberlandesgerichts münchen ganz
überwiegend bestätigt und zwar deshalb
weil auch der bundesgerichtshof gesagt
hat schärpe ist mittäterin an der
gesamten mord serie
den raubüberfällen usw von uwe bernhardt
und uwe mundt los und sie ist schuldig
des zehnfachen mordes und weiterer
versuchter morde unter anderem sowie der
mitgliedschaft lichten beteiligung an
einer terroristischen vereinigung
sie hat der bgh hat auch die revision
weiterer angeklagter als offensichtlich
unbegründet verworfen
es wurde also noch nicht mal verhandelt
nur auch das wurde jetzt neu festgelegt
am zweiten dezember wird mündlich
verhandelt werden über die revision des
generalbundesanwalts gegen den
unterstützer andré emminger darüber
werden wir euch nochmal gesondert
informieren das hat so ein bisschen
anderen hintergrund weil da geht es eben
um eine revision der staatsanwaltschaft
und über die wird traditionell in der
justiz ich sag jetzt mal das ist einfach
so das ist halt so über die wird dann in
aller regel schon mündlich verhandelt
wohingegen revisionen der angeklagten
wesentlich seltener mündlich verhandelt
werden genau das will jetzt aber beate
treppe mit ihren drei verteidigern
erzwingen sie hat also anhörungsrüge
erhoben gemäss 356 a strafprozessordnung
und gegenvorstellung erhoben weil sie
sich in ihrem anspruch auf rechtliches
gehör vor allem verletzt sieht sie sieht
sich auch noch verletzt in ihrem recht
auf ein faires verfahren und auf die
garantie des gesetzlichen richters das
hat aber der bgh praktisch alles unter
den tisch fallen lassen ehrlich gesagt
formal betrachtet auch zurecht er hätte
dazu was sagen können aber nicht müssen
denn der anhörungsrüge damit kann man
halt eben rügen dass man im verfahren
nicht richtig gehört wurde wie kommt sie
ihre verwundert oder nach diesen schweiß
nicht mehr wie viel 400 irgendetwas
prozesstagen ja genau der vorwurf ist
auch nicht dass sie am olg münchen nicht
richtig gehört wurde sondern der vorwurf
ist dass der bgh ihre revision verworfen
hat ohne den verteidigern noch mal die
möglichkeit zu geben sich gegen eine
rechtsauffassung quasi zu wehren die sie
für geändert halten ohne dass man ihnen
das mitgeteilt hatte also es geht halt
darum dass beate jappy ja nie am tatort
war und von anfang an war halt die frage
kriegen wir dann im mittäterschaft hin
und das olg münchen hatte sich ziemlich
einen abgebrochen um die mittäterschaft
zu begründen und der bgh hat das ehrlich
gesagt relativ kurz nicht hat das waren
40 oder 50 seiten also kein vergleich zu
den tausenden seiten die das olg münchen
abgeliefert hatte hat das relativ
einfach mit ja beantwortet und die
verteidiger argumentieren jetzt der bgh
hätte dabei seine rechtsprechung
geändert zur mittäterschaft und vor
allem den bislang nötigen konkreten
beitrag zu jeder einzelnen tat nicht
mehr verlangt sondern gesagt na ja das
kann man halt ausgleichen auch wenn man
nicht zu jeder einzelnen tag beigetragen
hat durch ein übergeordnetes ziel wobei
ich das wirklich in doppelter hinsicht
für nicht überzeugend halte zum einen ja
klar das ging nur es ging jetzt um die
hörstel beim bgh und nicht am olg
münchen und trotzdem war diese frage
mittäterschaft die alles überragende
frage dieses verfahrens von anfang an
war das die argumentation des
generalbundesanwalts gewesen und nichts
wurde so ausführlich diskutiert wie wie
diese frage vor dem oberlandesgericht
münchen und ich glaube was dem was die
verteidiger argumentieren auch im
plädoyer übrigens ist wirklich
hinlänglich bekannt zum anderen weiß ich
nicht ob ich die auffassung teilen würde
das die sich ziemlich einen abgebrochen
haben beim olg münchen bei der annahme
von mittäterschaft im fall beate tape
ist weil ja wenn man sich an die
definition der mittäterschaft oder der
tat herrschaft
erinnert ja durch den durch die justiz
oder durch die rechtsprechung dann ist
es ja immer wir lassen die ihr diese
subjektive tatherrschaft ausreichend
schon immer die sagen zwei jahres muss
irgendwas auch es muss auch eine
vorbereitungshandlung also irgendeine
handlung muss es gegeben haben es reicht
aber eine
vorbereitungshandlung wenn der wille
sozusagen ein plus beim willen kann eben
auch ein minus bei der tatausführung
kompensieren also das war ein
subjektiver begriff anders als zb claus
roxin der ja sozusagen der film hat der
tat herrschafts lehre ist der immer
gesagt hat das muss auch objektiv
wirklich was beträchtliches dazu kommen
es gibt jetzt strafverteidiger die
kritisieren das ist insgesamt
eine tendenz gibt in der rechtsprechung
die den tatsächlichen tatbeitrag immer
unwichtiger findet ja und eben das
subjektive
wir haben also das kann man auch
vielleicht in anderen fällen ich will
jetzt nicht zu weit gehen aber beim
demjanjuk verfahren also da gibt es eine
änderung der rechtsprechung in den in
den in den ss fällen wobei es da nicht
um tatherrschaft geht sondern um
beihilfe aber da fragt man halt was muss
man eigentlich gewusst haben und wozu
man hatten ja da gibt es ja eine
änderung und daher gibt es eben jetzt ja
verteidiger die analysieren und sagen
also man ist so schnell jetzt schon in
der strafbarkeit drin ja das ist so aber
die argumente natürlich auch ich will
nicht sagen prodomo aber sie doch das
ist ja ihr job ist es ihr job gehört und
die sehen eine expansive tendenz in der
rechtsprechung darüber kann man
sicherlich in fachkreisen diskutieren
ich halte nur diese argumentation im
fall schicke die er vom gba von
generalbundesanwalt entwickelt wurde das
ist halt ein trio ist es zu dritt im
untergrund gelebt hat und das
wechselseitige tatbeiträge hatte und es
ihr beitrag eben nicht nur die
verwaltung der finanzen war sondern die
sogenannte legendi rung also die
aufrechterhaltung der fassade einer
bürgerlichen fassade die eben dazu führt
dass die anderen beiden in
ruhe sage ich meinen vorzeichen morgen
durchs land ziehen können während sie zu
hause
darüber wachte das niemand komische
fragen stellt und
sagen halt ohne ihren tatbeitrag wären
die morde überhaupt nicht möglich
gewesen dass es eine argumentation die
in dieser sage ich mal in so einer
konstellation denn bisher noch nicht
vorkam aber jetzt auch nicht so
überraschend ist also ich fand es
ehrlich gesagt ich bin nicht so ganz bei
dir ich hatte auch etwas probleme mit
dem mit dem in das urteil des bgh weil
es wurde halt schon sehr also aus meinem
aus meiner sicht wurde da schon einiges
durcheinander geworfen und zwar ging es
ja dann hat der bgh das so ein bisschen
begründet wieso eine art psychischer
mittäterschaft und
hat sehr sehr stark abgestellt auf
dieses gemeinsame tat interesse und
darauf dass im prinzip dieser gesamtetat
plan ja darauf basiert habe das bad
apple bei jeder tat eben gerade nicht am
tatort war sondern zu hause saß und
versprochen hatte wenn das schief geht
wenn ihr euch wie wir es besprochen
haben dann in die luft jagt oder euch
abfackelt wort er war dann werde ich
dafür sorgen dass bekannt wird dass
diese serie auf den nsu zurückzuführen
ist und damit werden wir dann maximal
angst und schrecken verbreiten und am
ende das war ja quasi das fernsehen
dieser drei terroristen ohren das kann
man sich ja nicht sagen und am ende dann
quasi alle migranten und migrantinnen
freiwillig deutschland verlassen und das
fand ich jetzt schon also so hart diese
staat interesse zu einem objektiven
tatbeitrag zu erklären fand ich schon
ehrlich gesagt vor allem in dieser kürze
doch auch ein bisschen durcheinander und
da muss ich auch sagen das kannte ich
bisher aus den bgh senat nicht aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass es am ende nichts
ändern wird insofern sind wir am ende
gleich so weit auseinander denn dass sie
ist halt eine anhörungsrüge also es kann
nur darum gehen bin ich hier irgendwie
übergangen worden hat das gericht mit
irgendwas was ich hätte sagen können
nicht zugehört und der bgh hat jetzt
auch wieder sehr knapp gesagt nee also
bei aller liebe nein wir haben weder
irgendwelchen verfahrens stoff verwertet
zudem beate treppe nicht angehört worden
sei noch haben wir irgendwas irgendwie
vorbringen von beate übergangen sondern
der bg hat eben auch gesagt hat nun
wirklich im revisionsverfahren
umfangreich zur frage ihrer
mittäterschaft liche beteiligung
vorgetragen und wir sind auch nicht dazu
verpflichtet irgendwie selbst wenn wie
hier irgendwie unsere rechtsprechung
ändern würden oder so da müssen wir
nicht darauf hinweisen wie unsere
rechtsauffassung zu der sache ist dazu
gibt es einfach überhaupt keine pflicht
der senat sagt aber auch ganz klar wir
haben unsere rechtsprechung eigentlich
gar nicht geändert die stimmt auch
weiterhin mit denen anderer senate
überein und wir haben auch überhaupt
nicht auf den objektiven tatbeitrag
irgendwie verzichtet oder da so eine art
kompensation durch ein übergeordnetes
tat interesse reingelassen was es bisher
nicht gab wobei das ja sogar zugelassen
ist also das ist ja ständige
rechtsprechung dass man sagt ein was ich
gesagt habe ein minus in der ausführung
kann durch ein plus kompensiert werden
das hat ja schon gibt das sagen auch
alle anderen senat also insoweit stimmt
das schon aber natürlich so in den
details fand ich jetzt schon auch
durchaus irgendwie bedenklich nur also
der der bgh es ja nicht seine eigene
super revisionsinstanz ich kann halt
nicht hingehen und sagen
irgendwie die entscheidung gefällt mir
nicht und deswegen bitte noch mal neu
und das ganze im wege einer jetzt
ausschließlich noch möglichen
anhörungsrüge sagt auch dass er damit
nicht nur für die hörerinnen und hörer
die sich da noch mal vertieft mit
beschäftigen wollen erinnere ich noch
mal an die entscheidungen im
zusammenhang mit dem deutschen herbst
also die raf urteile wo man ja auch
schon argumentiert hat mit da gab es ja
die sogenannten kommandos ja also ein
zusammenschluss von mehreren personen
die
einen mord begehen wollten einen
raubüberfall oder einen sonstigen dieser
diese attentate
auch hier auf kaufhäuser und ähnliches
und da hat man ja auch immer gesagt wer
mitglied eines kommandos ist selbst wenn
er nicht am tatort x 600 nicht
geschossen hat selbst wenn er nur
irgendwo war und aufgepasst hat das
niemand
bemerkt wird das war ja bei der f bis
zum ende so dass man häufig nicht wusste
wer jetzt eigentlich die tat wirklich
begangen hatte und die schweigen ja auch
die noch lebenden schweigen ja auch bis
heute darüber dass man da gesagt hat
also das ist spielt auch keine rolle
weil alle das so wollten und weil das
wechselseitig möglich gewesen wäre als
es ihn quasi vom zufall ab wer jetzt zum
tatort geht und wer andere aufgaben
waren und das stimmt natürlich so ganz
bei der beim nsu nicht weil die rollen
klar verteilt waren das war halt nicht
so dass manchmal wertet auch am tatort
war aber es lässt sich natürlich
durchaus eine linie zeichnen noch von
diesen von dieser rechtsprechung zum
thema raf um das
eigentlich sagt der bgh eben auch selbst
auch in diesem ns urteil darüber hat mir
auch damals in der ich glaube 175
erfolge gesprochen dass das ein spruch
podcast dass es ja eben nicht ausreichen
kann und darf dass ich mitglied bin in
einer terroristischen vereinigung
also denn das wäre halten eine völlige
überzeichnung also wenn allein die
mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen
vereinigung zu meiner mittäterschaft
führen würde dann bin ich halt auch
falsch aber in dem moment wo ich dann
sage eigentlich das übergeordnete ziel
dieser vereinigung reicht mir aus und
mittäterschaft daraus zu machen bin ich
halt ehrlich gesagt an dem ergebnis
recht nah dran aber wie gesagt es kommt
ende textilreinigung darauf an also das
kommando damals war ja auch nicht die
terroristische vereinigung die
terroristische vereinigung war hf und
das kommando war sozusagen ein
spezielles mordkommando für eine für
eine tat und dann beim nsu dadurch dass
es nur drei offiziell jedenfalls und
nach allem was man bisher weiß nur drei
mitglieder hat und die anderen im umfeld
unterstützt haben aber nicht mitglied
waren
ist es halt fällt es dann in dem fall
tatsächlich zusammen ein weites feld
bier aber
total weites feld wir kommen noch kurz
zur zur verfassungsbeschwerde ich
fürchte allerdings dass die ähnlich
ausgehen wird den sie hat am ende auch
das selbe ziel also auch mit dieser
verfassungsbeschwerde richten sich die
verteidiger von beate treppe eigentlich
gegen das bgh-urteil und wollen
erreichen dass der bgh noch mal mündlich
verhandelt und der verteidigung die
chance gibt sich zu dieser quasi als
neue empfundenen mittäterschaft
konstruktion zu positionieren also die
verteidiger halten das für eine
grundsätzliche frage nach der verwerfung
praxis des bgh das berühmte
offensichtlich unbegründet also quasi
ohne mündliche verhandlung einfach die
revision zu verwerfen und und sie meinen
eine abweisende entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts würde dazu
führen dass das das angeklagten das
recht auf rechtliches gehör
gerade in der letzten instanz entzogen
wird sozusagen also man darf gespannt
sein ob dabei jetzt mit den faktisch
selben argumenten was anderes rumkommt
ob das bundesverfassungsgericht
überhaupt diese diese
verfassungsbeschwerde zur entscheidung
annimmt das sind ja bekanntlich glaube
unter fünf prozent der eingereichten
verfassungsbeschwerden die überhaupt
angenommen werden und auch da wenn das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt sie sagen
selbst wenn die sagen okay das ist
vielleicht was dran dann der
argumentation aber es wäre ohnehin
nichts anders geworden auch wenn man
euch gehört hätte weil ihr habt einfach
genug gesagt dann wird die
verfassungsbeschwerde selbst wenn sie
angenommen würde wäre sie hat trotzdem
unbegründet von daher man darf gespannt
sein wie keep you posted so sieht es aus
und
wie keep you posted auch über das was
kommt
dass es in dieser woche eine na ja
eigentlich gar nicht so kleine und
uninteressante verhandlungen die wir
euch mal verhandlungen schwan
schlussanträge des generalanwalts die
wir euch mal vorstellen wollten weil die
nämlich eine sehr deutsche spezialität
betrifft und zwar wird der generalanwalt
am europäischen gerichtshof am
donnerstag seine schlussanträge vorlegen
zu der frage in welcher höhe man die
anwaltskosten für eine abmahnung wegen
filesharing übernehmen muss konkret geht
es darum ob die deutsche streitwert
deckelung auf 1000 euro
europarechtskonform ist also das ganze
ist ja so ein bisschen aus der
öffentlichkeit verschwunden weil einfach
filesharing glaube ich nicht mehr so
hipp ist seit man irgendwie bei spotify
sich ohnehin alles an köln hören kann
und dabei nur von werbung genervt wird
aber es geht eben darum das
internetnetzwerk urheberrechte verletzen
eben vor allem an musiktiteln film
computerspiele dadurch dass ein
geschütztes werk auf einer tauschbörse
im internet nicht nur selbst
herunterladen sondern dieses werk auch
allen anderen nutzern von tauschbörsen
zum download anbieten so was passiert
dann der rechteinhaber geht dann zum
anwalt und sagt dem anwalt körperlich
warum der anwalt schreibt dann den
verletzer oder die verletzungen an und
sagt hier abmahnung böse das darfst du
nicht noch mal machen und wir haben
jetzt und unterlassungsanspruch gib mal
eine unterlassungserklärung ab so
strafbewehrte unterlassungs
verpflichtung ein sehr schönes juristen
bord abmahnung bedeutet eigentlich das
wissen wahrscheinlich die allermeisten
auch wenn sie nicht jura studiert haben
macht das nicht mehr vor bösen böse wenn
du das daneben verspricht uns dass du es
nicht mehr macht und bei einem verstoß
dagegen wird es richtig teuer das
theoretisch fällt in diesem moment noch
gar kein geld an praktisch natürlich
doch und war die anwaltskosten des
abmahnenden also des inhabers der rechte
die muss man nämlich übernehmen wenn man
eine berechtigte abmahnung kassiert hat
und das kann je nach gegenstandswert
schon relativ teuer sein also auch ohne
dass da jetzt irgend eine strafe
verhängt würden oder so ist sind schon
diese abmahnkosten relativ ärgerlich
wenn es blöd läuft also da können auch
mal gut irgendwie 8 900 euro oder so
zusammenkommen und weil das dann alles
relativ stark eskaliert es so in den
jahren ich sag mal ich noch 211 2 12 213
gab es dann wirklich mal die sonst viel
zitierte abmahnindustrie also da haben
wirklich an welche ganze
geschäftsmodelle darauf aufgebaut dass
sie leute abgemahnt haben und sich dann
ich sage es mal deutlich so wie es war
die anwaltskosten für den ja sehr sehr
wenig aufwendigen
schrieb einer abmahnung sich geteilt
haben mit den mandanten so das war zum
teil clever aber absolut rechtmäßig zum
teil waren es auch rechtsmissbräuchlich
und deswegen gab es damals das gesetz
gegen unseriöse geschäftspraktiken das
ist 213 glaube ich in kraft getreten und
hat den 97 absatz 3 satz 1
urheberrechtsgesetz eingeführt und der
hat nämlich geklärt dass die kosten für
den anwalt durch den zug recht
abgemahnten urheberrechtsverletzer auf
1000 euro gegenstandswert begrenzt
werden müssen also wenn nicht ein
gegenstandswert von nur 1000 euro habt
dann ist es schon einiges weniger als
wenn ich zum beispiel sagen 50.000 euro
gegenstandswert ansätze was gar nicht so
selten ist wenn ich ein paar songs
heruntergeladen oder ein paar filme
irgendwie heruntergeladen hatte dh da
ist schon für die anwälte einiges an
geld verloren gegangen wobei es nicht
ganz richtig ist denn der anwalt kriegt
sein geld trotzdem der anwalt wird ja
erst mal von seinem auftraggeber bezahlt
das heißt er kriegt sein geld von seinem
mandanten also dem inhaber was weiß ich
der urheberrechte an dem musikstück das
der verletzer runtergeladen hat die
frage ist halt ob er diese kosten voll
erstattet kriegt und da hat man dann
gesagt nee das ist alles zu teuer für
die urheberrechtsverletzer selbst wenn
sie irgendwie sich falsch verhalten
haben ist deshalb unverhältnismässig und
dann haben sie diese streitwert
deckelung dar eingebaut was den anwälten
wahrscheinlich nicht so gut gefällt
genau also denn am ende ist es natürlich
so dass das werden dass ein guter
mandant ist und das ist ein unternehmen
dass du halt ein ständiger beratung
vertrittst dann wirst du im zweifel
einfach die anwaltskosten auch ein
bisschen runter kürzen und sagen na ja
wenn du davon dann irgendwie nur noch
zehn prozent zurück kriegs lieberman
dann kommen dann einigen wir uns am ende
auf 70 prozent oder sona das fanden die
anwälte jetzt natürlich auch alles nicht
so richtig schön am ende geht es aber
formal gesehen erst mal sozusagen zu
lasten des rechteinhabers der einfach
sein geld nicht zurück bekommt weil
theoretisch muss er seinen anwalt
trotzdem komplett bezahlen es gibt nur
eine ausnahme also ganz wenige fälle in
diesen denen diese decke streitwert auf
1000 euro nicht eintritt nämlich wenn
das macht den besonderen umständen des
einzelfalls unwillig ist ganz ehrlich
eigentlich ist es das total selten also
das sind so fälle wo man dann
ausnahmsweise doch mal super viel zeit
investiert hat als anwalt super viel
arbeitsaufwand
also viel mehr als man normalerweise in
der abmahnung investiert war eigentlich
als absoluter ausnahmeregel gedacht aber
seit einigen jahren scheint dass mehrere
deutsche gerichte nicht so richtig zu
interessieren die legen diese
ausnahmeklausel doch recht
unkonventionell aus also sie wenden
diese unfähigkeit nämlich an also sie
wenden dann auf deutsch gesagt die
deckelung nicht an es ist also normaler
streitwert quasi als regelfall und
begründen ist immer damit dass verstöße
gegen die sogenannte enforcement
richtlinie am ende steht aber eigentlich
der gedanke dahinter das ist ja
eigentlich gar nicht so richtig einen
grund gibt ein rechtsverletzer so zu
schützen
der ja immerhin empfänger einer
berechtigten abmahnung war so und jetzt
hat das landgericht saarbrücken
vorgelegt und hat gesagt irgendwie das
sehen wir alles gar nicht ein
und für die abgemahnten verbraucherin
wäre das natürlich jetzt schon relativ
interessant wenn die deckelung kippen
würde dann würde das wieder deutlich
teurer werden also da müsste man schon
wieder wesentlich mehr anwaltskosten
berappen für die rechteinhaber wäre es
spannend wenn der ogh generalanwalt oder
am ende natürlich der bh dann erst das
ganze kippt weil sie dann wieder alles
erstattet kriegen würden und natürlich
auch für die anwältinnen und anwälte
denn wie gesagt bei dauer mandaten ist
das schon durchaus um einiges rentabler
wenn man die kosten voll vom gegner
erstarrte kriegt und sie nicht bei dem
eigenen an bei dem eigenen mandanten
geltend machen muss gerade weil das
damals in 213 halt alles ist ein riesen
wirbel war auch gerade in der
anwaltschaft als dann diese deckelung
eingeführt wurde auch weil ich es aber
sehr interessant finde dass die gerichte
einfach sagen wir machen mal den den
ausnahmefall zum regelfall werden wir
das irgendwie alles nicht gerechtfertigt
finden bin ich schon sehr gespannt was
der generalanwalt dazu sagen wird wenn
das urteil vorliegt sagen wir euch
natürlich bescheid
und kommen jetzt zu unserem
wunderschönen nicht lustigen leider in
dieser woche aber durchaus sehr sehr
gerecht helene erzählen
sondern ziemlich ernst ja es geht um
einen mann der fördermitglied ist der
partei dritter weg diese partei ist eine
als rechtsextrem eingestufte partei dazu
wenn ich jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen
was sagen und der mann hatte eine
waffenbesitzkarte jetzt mal ganz kurz
vielleicht auch nur unter der rubrik
nerd eine kurze klarstellung bei mir das
schon mal mehrfach unsere leser gesagt
haben dass man ja immer gemeinsam vom
waffenschein spricht das ist aber was
anderes es gibt einerseits die
waffenerlaubnis das ist quasi der echte
der echte verwaltungsakt der dich
berechtigt eine waffe zu hause zu haben
wo du eben diese ganzen anforderungen an
die zuverlässigkeit zum beispiel
erfüllen muss und dann gibt es den
sogenannten waffenschein was tatsächlich
eine art von shine ist also ein papier
wo draufsteht dass du dass du die waffe
zum beispiel führen kann es außerhalb
eines befriedeten besitztums oder
ähnlich und das ist auch zeitlich
beschränkt und so also es ist es
tatsächlich was anderes und wir reden
hier über die waffenerlaubnis also die
auch genannte
waffenbesitzkarte genau so und hier ging
es eben darum dass das
verwaltungsgericht cottbus dem man diese
waffenbesitzkarte entzogen hat und das
damit begründet hat dass er eben
mitglied des dritten weges sei und hat
dann noch argumentiert also hat einige
beispiele angeführt dass der mann
offensichtlich wirklich nicht mit beiden
beinen auf dem boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung steht in dem
er etwa gesagt hat gegen die errichtung
eines flüchtlings wohnheims mit den
worten protestiert hat ich werde nicht
tatenlos zusehen wie unser volk
vernichtet wird außerdem hat er wohl zu
hause ein gedenkstein mit wehrmachts
hellmund eichenkranz errichtet war es
eben eindeutig symbole der
rechtsradikalen szene sind und was ist
jetzt auch nicht so überraschend ich
glaube wer schon mal so ein kampf stand
gesehen hat und wie mir das mal passiert
es auch gehört hat mit wirklich dumpfer
musik untermalt und so da kann man sich
jetzt schon durchaus vorstellen
irgendwie wer da so mitgemacht hat und
wie solche gedenksteine aussehen aber
das heißt das vg cottbus hat dann
einfach gesagt so du bist hier mitglied
oder hasst den ich glaube der hat sogar
den fall irgendwie das den dritten weg
nur unterstützt höher damit und damit
bist du automatisch waffenrechtlich
unzuverlässig oder wie also automatisch
nicht da hilft tatsächlich auch ein
blick ins waffengesetz das ist § 5 das
waffengesetz ist unsere einige
hörerinnen haben uns aufgefordert
häufiger auch mal paragrafen zu ziehen
was wir hier gerne so recht so recht
genau und diese norm ist eine typische
würde ich mal sagen
verwaltungsrechtliche norm da geht es
wird die zuverlässigkeit definiert und
die zuverlässigkeit ist eine
voraussetzung um die waffenerlaubnis zu
bekommen und da gibt es verschiedene
rubriken wann jemand als nicht
zuverlässig anzusehen ist und da ist es
zum beispiel die erforderliche
zuverlässigkeit besitzen personen nicht
die zum beispiel wegen eines verbrechens
rechtskräftig verurteilt sind das sind
die klaren fälle und dann gibt es die
anderen fälle von die erforderliche
zuverlässigkeit besitzen personen in der
regel nicht also das ist die so genannte
regel vermutung die wo dann ja immer der
berühmte ausnahmefall möglich ist warum
es dann im in bestimmten konstellationen
doch geht und in diesem die bei unter
diese regel fälle fallen einerseits
mitgliedschaft ihn zum beispiel
verfassungswidrigen parteien wo
allerdings die verfassungswidrigkeit vom
bundesverfassungsgericht nachbarn auf 46
bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz
festgestellt werden muss und das ist bei
dem dritten weg nicht erinnern muss man
ja das ist eine erlaubte patina und das
wundert auch nicht besonders wenn man
sich die an die npd rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts erinnert wo er
das verfassungsgericht klar gesagt hatte
die programmatik der partei widerspricht
komplett unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung aber die
partei ist so unbedeutend und hat so
wenig tatsächliche einflussmöglichkeiten
das sozusagen eine gefährdung unseres
systems nicht zu erwarten ist und wenn
man jetzt sieht das der dritte weg
tatsächlich nur 600 mitglieder hat und
natürlich in keiner einzigen in keinem
einzigen parlament irgendwie auch nur
die leiseste chance hat einzuziehen oder
auch nicht in einem auf kommunaler ebene
irgend etwas zu reißen ist klar dass
auch das verfassungsgericht diese partei
nicht verbieten wird übrigens ist es
interessant weil der dritte weg
tatsächlich sagt wer sich wirklich an
wahlen beteiligt der unterstützt schon
irgendwie die demokratie in diesem in
diesem system und da sie das system so
sehr verachtet
jedenfalls habe ich es gelesen wollen
sie da gar nicht so mitmachen ich weiß
nicht ob das der aktuellste stand ist
weil weil sie jetzt wahlkampf ja gemacht
haben ja genau sie haben wahlkampf
gemacht ich weiß nicht ob man da
irgendwie also sie treten ja auch
eigentlich fast immer nur im wahlkampf
in erscheinung weil sie dann in das
waren dann in diesem jahr zum beispiel
diese berühmten plakate hängt die grünen
und so weiter
eigentlich nur in solchen fällen hört
man von dieser partei die sind eben
offiziell einer partei meines wissens
waren die glaube ich früheren verein und
haben dann eben aus genau solchen
gründen dass man als partei natürlich
andere rechte hat als irgendein
privatrechtlicher verein quasi
umfirmiert sie sind eben auch nicht
verboten genau wie du sagst weil sie
einfach zu relevant sind um es mal auf
deutsch zu sagen und deswegen sind wir
dann im waffengesetz in dem regelfall
mann ist waffenrechtlich unzuverlässig
weil man damit glied es richtig also ja
ich quasi komplett ausschluss waren ja
gerade bei der frage was ist mit der
verfassung einer verfassungswidrigen
partei haben wir nicht jetzt muss man ja
noch weiter lesen und da landet man
jetzt bei der rubrik bei denen also
personen bei denen tatsachen die annahme
rechtfertigen dass sie in den letzten
fünf jahren bestrebungen verfolgt haben
die gegen die verfassungsmäßige ordnung
gerichtet sind das ist hier der fall der
einschlägig ist weil das eben beim
dritten weg eindeutig der fall ist also
da hat das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz eben festgestellt dass
es sich um eine rechtsextreme bestrebung
handelt es gibt ein zitat aus dem bmi wo
es heißt das eine rechtsextremistische
antisemitische und menschenfeindliche
gruppierung die zudem nicht bereit sein
sich von gewalttaten hinreichend zu
distanzieren also man kann über die
wirklich allerlei offizielle äußerungen
lesen zum beispiel auch im
verfassungsschutzbericht von 2017 ist
die rede davon dass der dritte weg das
wertesystem der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung ablehne und
nach einer gesellschaftsordnung nach
einer gesellschaftsordnung in anlehnung
an das an den historischen
nationalsozialismus strebe also all das
ist erfüllt ziemlich klar den tatbestand
der verein gegen die verfassungsmäßige
ordnung gerichtet und so ist dieses
waffengesetz eben auch einschlägig jetzt
ist noch die frage gibt es wir haben ja
gesagt regelfall gibt es irgendwelche
gründe die eine andere betrachtung in
diesem fall rechtfertigen da könnte man
sich auf die idee kommen zu sagen naja
es halb fördermitglied nur aber so kommt
eben wieder dieser ährenkranz ins spiel
wenig zitiert habe und die äußerungen
vor dem flüchtlingsheim ganz
offensichtlich teilt er eins zu eins die
programmatik und ausrichtung des dritten
weges und insofern würde ich sagen ist
es nach der argumentation also nach der
rechtlichen eine ziemlich klare sache
und wir finden
das heißt ja nicht dass das urteil nicht
auch gerecht sein kann sondern im
gegenteil in dem fall ist es noch nicht
so vor juristisch überzeugend als auch
entspricht es dem was wir für recht und
billig erachten genau ist war schon fast
alternativlos um dieses sprichwort mal
zu nutzen das vg cottbus in diesem fall
so entschieden hat zutiefst gerecht und
ich würde sagen dass war es von uns für
diese woche ich glaube es bleibt
spannend es ist viel los im bundestag
geht wird rund gehen davon kann man
glaube ich ausgehen bleibt uns gewogen
bleibt gesund generikums post habe so
genau apropos post wie immer unter
einspruch podcast geht faz.de freuen wir
uns über
anmerkungen hinweise auf vielleicht
andere gerechte urteile die wir nicht
gesehen haben oder auch kritik gerne
auch berichtigungen falls wir als ich
ein kleiner fehler eingeschlichen haben
sollte
ging und ich wünsche allen noch eine
gute woche für die rauch und wir sehen
wir hören uns also ich und die höfe im
dezember wieder bier und wir wollen uns
in der kommenden woche mit corinna
zusammen wieder kommt gut durch die
woche und bleibt gesund das muss man
jetzt sagen
[Musik]